we have a change at the top here at CBS
News seeing my big smile all 116 smiling
day Susan Zorinsky is a fixture at this
network for 45 years she's our new
president and senior executive producer
Z that's what we call her in the
building is the first woman to be
president of CBS News CBS acting CEO
that's Joe I&L Oh announced last night
that Susan Zorinsky will move up from
her longtime role as senior executive
producer 48 hours he noted that she has
touched almost every part of CBS news
since she started as a production clerk
back in 1972 Wow
she was also the model for Holly
Hunter's character in the movie
broadcast news Zorinsky replaces David
Rhodes will step down after eight years
as CBS news president he is staying at
this network as senior advisor tonello
and CBS News I tell you when I heard the
news last night I was doing the happy
dance on the hula the happy dance on the
Upper West Side because I feel that we
were sort of like a ship not sinking but
taking on water and I feel that she is
somebody who can right the ship because
she gets us she knows us and by us I
mean this organization she's been here
for a very long time she is a smart
cookie and she is a badass in every
sense of the word I'm she know she is
known for her original reporting exactly
great producing skills she is a great
journalist and in addition to that she
also happens to have a kind heart and
cares about the people that work here so
a new day is on the rise a year he's
keeping that producer title as well it's
pretty cool when your boss goes by Z to
enough energy to power this entire
studio keeping producer title but I'm
gonna stick with President yeah Adam
president Susan Zorinsky great news for
all of us